okay hold on just a second before you
dislike this video and hear me out for
just a bit I'm genuinely very excited
for the 3a and 3 XL and I think this was
a genius move by Google which I'll cover
in just a bit but I wanted to take a
little bit of a different approach with
this video than the other 20 or so pixel
videos in your feed these phones
obviously have a ton of upside for the
money but when Google revealed the price
I was shocked and my first instinct was
wondering what are the downsides let's
get right into every corner cut to get
the pixel 3/8 down to $399 and then I'll
give you my honest opinion on it
starting off with the heart of the phone
the CPU instead of the Snapdragon 1845
the pixel 3a uses the mid-level 670 that
is also in Samsung's new s5e tablet this
means that it will be a bit slower for
tasks that push the processor and
loading apps will take a bit longer
comparing benchmarks the pixel 3/8 is
about 30 to 40 percent faster but it's
not that far off from that pixel - and
will likely have better battery life
than both but on the graphics side
there's a huge difference even between
the pixel 2 and 3/8 so gaming won't be a
strong suit of this new phone along with
that we are missing the pixel visual
court is aynd to process images faster
and with less power
Google isn't removing any of the softer
features but this will likely mean
you'll need to wait a bit longer for
your HDR or Porsche photos to be
processed we're also missing something
else related to photos and that's the
ultra wide selfie camera on the front
that's not a big deal to me personally
especially at this price point but let
me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below
the bass RAM and storage is exactly the
same as the flagships but the 3a phones
are limited to just that so if you need
more physical space you'll have to look
elsewhere along with that you don't get
unlimited photo storage at full original
quality which was a big pixel selling
point but your images will need to be
compressed just like every other Google
photo app user the back of the phones
look very similar to the flagships but
they no longer use soft touch glass
instead we have a nice quality plastic
personally the soft touch glass always
felt slightly plasticky to me anyways so
this isn't a deal breaker unfortunately
with that change to other features that
I care about have been removed
that's wireless charging and water
resistance once you get used to these
comforts it's hard to go back flipping
to the front we
have dual speakers but they are no
longer both front firing I really want
to hear how a 3a speakers sound if hooba
pulls it off right it should still sound
great like the iPhone 10s and Samsung's
s10 along with that the pixel buds are
no longer included in the Box the
displays are still OLED which is
fantastic but if we take a look at the X
L model the resolution is slightly lower
and overall the phone size is larger and
has thicker bezels both pixel 3-days
also lack HDR support which likely means
that they won't get as bright as the
flagships google is also using dragon
tail glass instead of Gorilla Glass and
it should still have similar scratch
resistance but it will be more prone to
cracks the last big thing I want to
touch on is the LTE speeds the pixel
three A's used snapdragons x12 modem
which means the maximum download speeds
are about half of that of the pixel 3s
and wasn't three times slower than the X
24 and the Galaxy S tens which we raved
about I do want to point out that most
carriers can't even get close to these
maximum speeds but in the real world
these faster modems do give you faster
download speeds and potentially better
reception alright enough with the
negatives let's talk about why I'm
excited I do also want to mention that I
will be getting this phone in tomorrow
so we are going to be doing a series of
comparisons along with the full review
so if you want to check that out make
sure you're subscribed and you have
those notifications enabled first off
the price 399 and 479 are fantastic
price points in a world where phones are
coming in at $1000 or even more and
that's basically half compared to the
pixel threes I really liked the Google
Nexus phones because they had sake
Android and a great price point but
their biggest downsides were always the
cameras Google is going back to their
roots with good phones like good prices
but now with a great camera like I said
at the start I think this is a really
smart move the pixel 3s are known by
enthusiasts for their excellent cameras
and the 3a has the same exact one
personally it wasn't my favorite because
I thought I had a bit too much contrast
and the white balance was too cool in
the Verge's video they showed off a
series of side by side shots and
interestingly one set of images had less
contrast and warmer colors they didn't
say which one is which but I presumed
the pixel three was the one that had
cooler tones since I can consistently
spot it in different camera comparisons
if so I think this camera will be
even better at least to my eyes and even
without that visual core this will be by
far the best smartphone camera for the
money we'll be doing some camera
comparisons with our pixel 3a so make
sure you're subscribed the second
biggest shocker is the display no it's
not the best but it's still an OLED
which is awesome and unlike the iPhone
10 R it still has a high resolution
because of that I think this screen
should be great to look at and that's
not even mentioning the fact that it
doesn't have a knotch
the battery powering the screens are
larger with a pixel 3a XL coming in at
3,700 milliamp hours which one paired to
the still high but lower res display
should result in great battery life and
also an easier time for the lower end
GPU and CPU to handle and another big
shocker is the headphone jack a lot of
us enthusiasts have moved to wireless
but for the average person who is an
attack head this part is important now
that these phones are going to be
available at local stores I think Google
is going to have a much easier time
selling these and with the low price
points and great cameras I think that
reps will be highly recommending them to
the average phone user let us know what
you think about the pixel 3a and 3a Axl
down in the comment section below this
has been max with Mac's tech and I'll
see you guys in the next video